there's a scene in 2019 s little woman
were Saoirse Ronan and Timothy Shalom a
dance outside giant windows that look
into a party where everyone else is
dancing in the 1994 adaptation this
scene is filmed with Joe and Laurie
dancing in a study dining room and
hallway both sequences established Joe
and Laurie as Outsiders in society but
what separates the 1994 film from the
2019 adaptation is the staging the 1994
film uses four set pieces while gerweck
uses only one which more effectively
positions Joe and Laurie as outsiders
where gerweck stages a scene is just one
way she illustrates her genius and it's
one of the three reasons she deserved to
win or at least get nominated for Best
Director at the Oscars
we all felt it coming in several awards
shows leading up to the Oscars women
were left out including former Oscar
nominee and supposed Shue and Greta
Gerwig but as gerweck writes in her
screenplay what women are allowed in the
club of geniuses anyway and I'm so sick
of people saying that love it let's
start with garrix brilliant blocking a
hallmark of a good scene is when
everyone in that scene has something to
do
Berwick takes this concept to the next
level with movement characters
effortlessly moved in and out of focus
in their scenes at precisely the right
time to illustrate this we can take a
look at the scene where the Marches
returned home from giving the Hummels
their Christmas breakfast I know he did
now let's break this down all the
marches come through the door
Amy notices the spread first and
everybody follows her around the table
we learned that she likes nice things
and that she's aware of material needs
next Joe leads the group to the window
when she hears that the spread came from
the Lawrences she's more idealistic
Marmee stays planted at the center of
the room because she's the anchor of the
family amy leads the group back to what
she cares about the feast with the
movement in the scene gerweck uses the
space to let her characters organically
move their familiarity makes it feel
like they really lived there but the
choreography also informs character
dynamics that are important to the story
Joe and Amy tend to lead but the meg
tend to follow Marmee holds everyone
together another great example of
movement and blocking is in this scene
between Meryl Streep and Saoirse Ronan
Joe and Aunt March are dramatic foils
where Joe is always moving Aunt Marge is
almost always still Joe has gone off to
look out the window
with this decision Berwick points out
again she's looking out for
possibilities is there a reason you
stopped reading Belgium
up March forces her back down to
continue reading reflecting her desire
to get joke back to earth the ensuing
comedic exchange shows that Joe does not
do well with being forced to sit still
no one makes their own way not really
least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well you are not married aren't
well that's because I'm rich
character-driven blocking expertly
executed let's talk about pace Emma
Watson describes the dialogue and little
woman in an interview with Sony Pictures
as having dashes at the end of each line
this means that the lines run together
it's not in vain gerweck describes the
effect created as choreographed chaos
and a cacophony of words and sounds now
you might be thinking wait if that's the
way the lines were written doesn't that
illustrate why it's a great screenplay
instead of why it's excellent directing
it's a great screenplay but delivery and
pace are a collaboration between
director and performer where exactly
does this character interrupt the other
these are decisions gerweck was making
in rehearsal and onset as the director
she knew exactly how she wanted the
dialogue to sound taking the word she'd
written and bringing them to life let's
take another look at the Christmas scene
to see this in action the scene starts
with a very fast rhythm but then it
slows to a perfectly engineered pace for
us to learn about the character dynamics
and relationships
his grandson Laurie put the idea into
his head I know he did we should make
friends with him Joey admires Laurie and
wants to be friends there's a very kind
man who lost his little girl when she
was only a child
mr. Laurence has a heart of gold Amy
sees Laurie romantically what could be
seen as purely expositional dialogue
it's transformed to natural family
discussion that anybody could see
themselves having around a dinner table
all that in a scene that's less than a
minute long
here's an example of a scene that tries
this technique but not to the same level
of success no the answer's no not not no
with excuses Rick and Randy overstep
each other in this conversation but why
doesn't it feel as natural it's the
movement and the pace most of the scene
plays out in a static wide shot but
instead of lending itself to the
tightness of the trailer the super wide
lens gives both characters more space
that they don't really utilize they both
stay planted on either side never
breaking the famous 180 degree line and
playing it very safe Leonardo DiCaprio
makes good choices to get ready through
the scene but Kurt Russell doesn't have
much to do the pacing of the
interruptions feels choreographed rather
than each actor trying to get the upper
hand in the conversation gerweck closely
collaborated with all creative
departments to create the perfect
staging for her scenes staging is a
choice of location for a scene while
blocking is the movement within this
space in the moment we mentioned earlier
her choice of staging adds new meaning
to a classic scene Joe and Louie dancing
wildly at the ball is a classic scene
from Louisa May Alcott's novel in the
book Joe explains to Lauri that you must
stay hidden because she scorched the
back of her dress so to bend the rules
Joe and Lori dancing the hallway
Berwick decides to go in a different
direction and stages the scene outside
of the gardener's house Gerlich told the
New York Times that she chose the stage
it in this way because you could see the
dancers inside and Lori and Joe having
their own dance party outside
what Gerwig accomplishes with this
staging is the idea of parallel reality
Joe and Lori moved in between the
windows with beau elegance and then
become who they really are in the space
between
we learn how they see the world and how
they view themselves as something
different in contrast in the 1994
adaptation the scene cuts back and forth
from Christian Bale and Winona Ryder to
the ballroom in order to show this
juxtaposition this is a classic film
technique to show contrast Berwick's
restaging adds a new layer of excitement
and visual metaphor another example of
excellent staging in the film occurs
when Jill and Bethenny Beach this is
perhaps the best use of girl it's placed
juxtaposition throughout the film she
navigates between past and present often
anchored by place this is a great
storytelling technique in the screenplay
but the staging of the two Beach scenes
in particular shows excellent directing
the pass is lit by a warm glow in the
present it's cloudy as if the joy has
gone out of the atmosphere the wind
pulls in the tide with a cloud of sand
Joe tries to hold Beth tight but she
can't save her the dramatic staging of
this moment shows that for all of Joe's
spirit she can't stop the inevitable
passing over gerweck for this nomination
perfectly illustrates the reason why
this film is so important it's easy to
see how scenes full of violence
explosions and life-or-death drama feel
important traditionally these themes are
more masculine it takes a very special
director to create a film about domestic
affairs without being tossed aside as a
chick flick little woman is important
because it's an adaptation about the
place of woman in the world and how
their passions outside of romantic
relationships are often overlooked the
distinctive style and flair of the film
is something only gerweck could achieve
[Music]
you